Bitte schön.
Also, ja, ich fange mit der Anamnisa an.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag. Mein Name ist Mehmet Melifis.
Ich bin auf dieser Station der Diensthaber, der als tätig ist.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchschrieben.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, bitte schön.
Ich bin auf der Strecke.
Ich werde ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Danach werde ich zu Ihrer aktuellen Beschwerden kommen.
Danach am Ende werde ich ein paar Fragen,
bezüglich Ihrer Familienvorgehricht, stellen.
Okay? Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
54 Jahre alt.
Mein Name ist Müller.
Wie heißt Ihr?
Peter.
Also, M-U-L-L-E-R.
Was ist Ihr genannt geboren?
Ich bin 2. April 1970 geboren.
1970.
Wie viele gehen Sie zur Seite?
Ich würde gerne sagen.
Wie viel wiegt Ihr?
1,80 Meter.
Herr Müller, was fühlst du uns heute?
Ich habe seit gestern Abend stärkste Bauchschmerzen.
Ich konnte die Nacht auch nicht schlafen.
Deswegen bin ich heute hier.
Ich habe wirklich sehr, sehr starke Bauchschmerzen.
Ich verstehe, dass Sie wegen Schmerzen nicht kurz schlafen können.
Wo sind die Schmerzen genau?
Im Oberbau.
Seit gestern haben Sie diese Beschwerde?
Seit gestern Abend.
Wie sind die Schmerzen?
Wir schreiben.
Stechen die Schmerzen, Brücken die Schmerzen,
ziehen die Schmerzen.
Alles klar.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich auch Rückenschmerzen habe.
Rückenschmerzen.
Wie sind die Schmerzen aufgetreten?
Sind sie langsam oder plötzlich aufgetreten?
Die waren plötzlich da.
Plötzlich hatte ich diese Schmerzen.
Ich musste nicht kümmern, konnte kaum atmen.
Ich habe die Nacht vorgestellt.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder verschwindelig?
Die werden es wenig, aber die sind die ganze Zeit da.
Jetzt habe ich stark Schmerzen.
Okay, herrmüller.
Zulich innen ein Schmerzbittel geben,
dann können Sie ein Superbindchen Schmerzmittel geben.
Ich habe wirklich stark Schmerzen.
Dann her kollegieren können Sie bitte
unseres Patienten ein Schmerzbittel bereiten?
Danke.
Was geben Sie mir denn nicht? Ich habe auch Schmerz mit Allergien.
Das ist wichtig.
Ich kann nicht alle Medikamente nehmen.
Ich frage mich, ob Sie eine Medikamente-Allergie haben.
Ich vertrage nur Allgien.
Okay.
Das ist ein anderes Schmerzbittel.
Was sollte sich keiner Sorgen machen?
Ich würde gerne fragen,
gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für Ihre Schmerzen?
Ich habe die ganze Zeit Schmerzen.
Ich weiß nicht.
Sie haben schon gesagt,
dass Ihre Schmerzen mit der Zeit verschwindelig haben?
Ja,
ich habe das Gefühl, das wird schlimmer.
Sie haben schon einmal gesagt,
dass Ihre Schmerzen mit der Zeit verschwindelig haben?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich habe gestern auch gebrochen,
bevor ich schlafen ging.
Wie oft?
Zwei Mal.
Ich habe das Gefühl, das wird schlimmer.
Es war zu oft,
aber immer in der Nacht habe ich erbrochen,
aber er da nur gelbe Süßigkeit rausgab.
Ja, Gerbeflüssigkeit.
Sie essen proudly,
oder?
Ich habe es von gestern Abend nicht mehr gegessen.
Ich finde das.
Ja natürlich, sonst werde ich es nicht erbrochen.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber, Stilfros oder Nachschmärz bemerkt?
Hab ich jetzt nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Gibt es Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Wasserlassen habe ich keine Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang, habe ich noch nicht gehabt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen, durchs Eishehaben gesagt,
dass wegen Schmerzen Sie kontinuierlich gut schlafen?
Ich habe kaum geschlafen, kaum.
Hab ich kaum geschlafen?
Haben Sie Lust, oder Kopf schmerzen, oder Gelein schmerzen?
Nein.
Danke sehr für die Informations.
Ich habe ein paar Frage bezüglich IRF-Vorgehs,
ich habe gibt es wichtige Forengerankungen von denen ich wissen soll,
zum Beispiel Blutöre, der Rheuchte-Bulletwert.
Ich habe zuerst vor zwei Jahren Blutab gegeben,
da hat mein Hausarzt mir gesagt, dass ich ihr Rheuchte-Bulletwert habe.
Seit wann haben Sie das Rheuchte-Bulletwert?
Ich habe vor zwei Jahren Blutab gegeben, das letzte Mal.
Aber er hat auch nichts gemacht, er hat gesagt,
ich soll aufpassen, dass ich mich vernünftig ernähre.
Also, sobald ich verstanden habe,
dass wurde bei Ihnen nicht festgeschmiert worden,
das war auffällig beim Blut.
Aber das war gut, vor zwei Jahren, genau.
Sie haben keine Diagnose festgeschmiert,
aber ich habe gesagt, ich habe Rheuchte-Bulletwert.
Okay, das war ja.
Gibt es andere Erkrankungen?
Nicht das Schüsse.
Was nehmen Sie für diese Rheuchte-Bulletwert ein?
Nehmen Sie Regenmusik und Medikamente ein?
Mein Herz gesagt, ich soll auf meine Ernährung achten.
Ich habe keine Schmerz, ich nehme auch einen Profen.
Ich vertreibe die Növalgen.
Wurdun Sie schon mal operiert?
Nein, ich war noch nie auf der Ernährung.
Gibt es Abgegen von Növalgien?
Gibt es bestimmte Allergen oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Nicht das Schüsse.
Ich würde gerne noch mal auf die Növalgen.
Ich würde gerne auf die Növalgien.
Ich würde gerne noch mal fragen,
haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Abgesehen von dieser Erbrechung,
Überkeit, Gelbeflüssigkeit im Erbrochen
und Verstöpfung haben Sie irgendetwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Ich habe keine Verstöpfung.
Sie haben mir gesagt, seit gestern
Sie konnten nicht Stuhl machen.
Ich habe keine Stuhlgang.
Ich habe keine Verstöpfung.
Ich habe die Beschwerden, die seit gestern Abend.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie rauchen, Herr Müller.
Ich habe vor zehn Jahren aufgehört.
Vor zehn Jahren haben Sie aufgehört.
Das ist sehr gut, das freut mich.
Aber vorher, wie viel habe ich?
Ich habe ungefähr 20, 20 oder 15 bis 20 Jahre
aufgehört.
Wie viel?
15 bis 20 Jahre, immer wieder aufgehört, angefangen.
Ich würde sagen, 15 bis 20 Jahre.
Ich meine, ein Paket?
Wie viel?
Ich war so eine halbe Schachtel.
Aber regelmäßig.
Trinken Sie Alkohol, Herr Müller?
Ja.
Trinken Sie, wie oft trinken Sie?
Ich trinke, als Feierabend.
Jeden Tag nach dem Feierabend trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja.
Mit den Kollegen dran.
Was trinken Sie?
Wie viel trinken Sie?
Wir trinken.
2, 3 ungefähr.
Ein paar, ja.
Diese Freigestelle, ich, jedem, mit der nehmen Sie sich nicht persönlich.
Nehmen Sie sonstige Drogen?
Nein.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob wichtige Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie vorgeschichtet sind.
Leiden, leben Ihre Eltern, Ihre Vater?
Wir sind beide verstorben.
Ja, dann.
Wer ist gestorben?
Beide.
Es ist mir leid.
Wann sind Sie gestorben und woher sind Sie gestorben?
Die sind schon länger gestorben, da war ich noch jung, die haben Autounfall gehabt.
Es ist mir wirklich leid.
Was ist dir vom Beruf, Herr Müller?
Ich arbeite als
Systematministrator.
Sind Sie Kinder, sind Sie verheiratet oder leidig?
Geziehde.
Sind Sie Kinder, aber?
Nein.
Ich bin für mich alle wichtige Fragen.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben,
oder etwas wissen möchten,
dann können Sie kommen.
Ich verstehe, dass Sie den Grund Ihrer Beschwerden schnellstmöglich sind.
Aber nach der Untersuchung
und einige begreibende Verfahren,
das kann ich genauer sagen.
So seit, kann ich leider Ihnen so wenig sagen.
Mein Kollege hat ein Herzinfarkt.
Es geht hier nicht.
Mein Kollege hat ein Herzinfarkt vor drei Wochen.
Ich verstehe Ihre Sorgen, aber es geht hier nicht.
Ein Herzinfarkt.
Aufapplause.
Aber ich weiß.
Aber ich verstehe Ihre Sorgen, aber es geht hier nicht.
Però es geht hier nicht.
Ich verstehe Ihre Sorgen, aber es geht hier nicht.
Um Dann d atoms um
Eine Herzinfarkt,
Ich muss dafür ein schnell EKG schreiben, aber wir werden in einigen Minuten alle diese
Unterversorgung durchführen.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen und ich werde jetzt zu meinem Oberarzt gehen und Ihre Beschwerde
mit dem noch mal besprechen.
Danach werde ich bei Ihnen noch mal.
Verstanden, okay.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Herr Müller, hat Beschwerden gestern nach einer Nahrungsaufnahme aufgetreten?
Nein, später erst.
Okay, die zweite Frage ist, hatten Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden?
Ja, ich habe schon mal solche Beschwerden gehabt, aber nicht so stark wie jetzt.
Das ist schon ungefähr drei, vier Jahre her.
Okay, danke für die Frage.
Ja, eine Frage.
Ja, haben Sie Medikamente gegen die Schmerzen eingenommen?
Ich habe gestern Iguprofen genommen, ja.
Ja, wie viel Medikamenten?
600.
Ja, einmal, ja?
Einmal genommen, ja.
Hat ein wenig geholfen, da konnte ich ein bisschen schlafen, aber jetzt bin ich hier.
Ja, zweite Frage.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskalifon eins bis zehn vorbei?
Ein sehr leichter, sehen sehr starken Schmerzen, als gebrückt.
Ja, mindestens acht.
acht, ja.
Danke.
Okay, danke.
Herr Müller,
wo genau sind die Schmerzen in Oberhoussen,
ja, in Oberhoussen?
Schmerzen im Oberbau, in der Mitte und der rechten Oberbau oder linke?
Mittig, würde ich sagen. Mittig.
Leiden Sie unter Engelgefühl Brustschmerzen?
Brustschmerzen nicht, aber unter der Brust ist das.
Was ist das?
Das ist nur Stechen, Ziehend, Drückend, irgendwie alles.
Strahlen die Schmerzen in den Drücken, haben Sie schon gesagt oder?
Hab ich schon gesagt, ja.
Wo genau die Strahlen die Schmerzen können Sie beschreiben?
Drücken.
Einfach rücken, okay, gut, danke.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Haben Sie eine gelbliche Verfarbung der Haut bemerkt?
Nein.
Okay, danke.
Noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe kein Nachtschweiß, ich habe kein Gewicht verloren.
Ja, ich habe gefragt, Herr Kollege.
Kommt gefragt?
Ja, ich möchte fragen, aber...
Ach so.
Ich habe kein Gewicht verloren.
Nein.
Beirabend, ein, zwei Mal Bier und noch andere Alkohol zum Beispiel.
Ja, am Wochenende.
Wie viele Jahre?
Also jetzt seitdem ich geschieden bin, ich bin seit ungefähr fünf Jahren geschieden, seitdem trinke ich ein bisschen mehr.
Meine Seite alle Fragen gestärkt, ich habe...
Ich war am Wochenende im Ausland.
Ja.
Ich war in Holland gewesen mit meinen Freunden zusammen.
Holland.
Ich war mit meinen Freunden in Holland gewesen, wir waren etwas unterwegs gewesen.
Darf ich fragen, habe du etwas der Dorvenis oder ungewöhnliches gelassen?
Ich denke nicht.
Ich habe ein Patient, namens Peter Mündler.
Er ist 54 Jahre alt und 65 kg schwer und 1 Meter 80 groß.
Er hat sich bei uns wegen Stehenden, Drückern und Plöstlich aufgetretene, Progredieren, Rücken und Oberbauchschmerzen vorgestellt.
Nein.
Die Folgen der Begleitdünkte muss sein.
Nein, nein, nein, bitte wiederholt.
Er hat sich bei uns wegen Stehenden, Drückern und Sichern, Plöstlich aufgetretene, Rücken und Oberbauchschmerzen.
Rücken und Strahlung.
Ja, ja.
Er hat sich bei uns wegen Strahlung vorgestellt.
Als Begleitsymptome seien den Patienten, nausen er immer sie zweimal, in Appetenz und Schlauchstörungen in so mehr aufgefallen.
Er habe seit gestern keinen Stuhl mehr.
Anvoropies, wo er, gab es keine Auffälligkeiten?
Ganz kurz. Also in so einem Nier ist glaube ich nicht der Fall. Es ist nur eine Nacht gewesen.
Ja.
Es ist jetzt nicht über mehrere Wochen gewesen. Es ist nur er konnte wegen dem Schmerz und nicht schlafen wahrscheinlich.
Ja, gut. Ja, ganz richtig.
An Vorerkrankungen seien ihm die folgende Vorerkrankungen bekannt.
Hyperlipidemie vor zwei Jahren, eigentlich, das war nur ein Stett, Stett als nur ein Verdacht.
Beim Hausars, das war auffällig.
Er hat eine erhöhte Blutfettwerte, aber die Diagnose wurde nicht gestellt.
Er nimmt bei Bedarf die Buchreffen ein.
Er ist gegen Novalgin allergisch.
Wie äußert sich, ich habe das nicht gefragt, aber die Patienten haben gesagt, dass er hat Jötum oder was haben sie gesagt?
Er hat Ausschlag gehabt, der hat nur die Allergie.
Die Allergie, die ich ausgerichtet exantan.
Und er ist seit zehn Jahren nicht raucher, aber sofort, ungefähr 10 Päckiers ist bekannt.
Er hat ein paar Bier, Drogen, Anamnese, verdreht.
Sein Vater und seine Mutter waren im Auto-Anfall gestorben.
Er arbeitet als Systemadminister und ist geschieden, hat keine Kinder.
Nach dem Annamnistischen Angaben gehe ich von einem Verdacht auf akut Punkreaties auf.
Deswegen würde ich gerne erstmal körperliche Untersuchungen machen.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen auch Autandisektionen, Akut-Gastreaties und Ulkus-Vetrücülü in Betracht.
Ich würde gerne in Betracht kommen.
Ich würde gerne Labo-Werte sehen und eine Erkage schreiben.
Ich würde gerne nach der körperlichen Untersuchung Labo-Werte sehen und eine Erkage schreiben.
Und andere Diagnostische bildgähden, die Verfahren wie Abdomenzoneografie und Röntgen in zwei Ebenen würde ich gerne fernlassen.
Haben Sie eine Schmerzmedikamente gegeben?
Ja, ich habe eine Medikamente gegeben.
Was haben Sie gegeben?
Ich habe Ibuprofen gegeben.
Ibuprofen geht nicht. Haben Sie ein Tablette gegeben?
Nein, ich weiß nicht, was ich gegeben habe.
Das hat mir jetzt nicht auf, aber ich habe eine Schmerzmedikamente gegeben.
Haben Sie ein paar Hatz-Tamol gegeben?
Ich gebe noch mal ein Tablette.
Sie haben eine Dolanzin gegeben, weil wenn Sie eine sehr starke Schmerz haben, 8 von 10, dann sind Sie eine sehr starke Schmerz.
Vielleicht haben Sie ein bisschen Morphine gegeben, damit Sie weniger Schmerzen haben, oder?
Ja, richtig.
Ich wollte meine letzte Semination, mir wurde gesagt, sag einfach, ich weiß nicht, wenn in Nordrhein-Westfalen die Semination der FSB prüfen kann.
Keine Semination.
Okay.
Gut.
War der Patient im Ausland gewesen?
Ja.
Mir wurde auch berichtet, dass er verreist war.
Er war verreist?
Er war verreist.
Wo war er?
In Holland, mir wurde gesagt.
Okay.
Trinkt ihr Patientalkohl?
Ja, trink er von bestimmten Anfassen und nach der Wochenende trink er Alkohol, ein paar Dosenbier.
Hat er gestern mehr getrunken als sonst?
Bitte nochmal.
Hat der Patient gestern mehr getrunken als sonst?
Das habe ich nicht gefragt.
War er alleine weg oder mit Partnern?
Ja, in unserem Gespräch wurde betont, dass er geschieden war.
Deswegen trinkt er mehr Alkohol.
Okay.
Aber Sie haben mich gefragt, ob er mit seinen Freunden war, feiern war, in der Disco war, party gemacht hat oder so.
Das habe ich leider nicht gefragt.
Ich werde gleich körperlich untersuchen.
Deswegen werde ich diese Frage noch mal stellen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Haben Sie vor den Patienten aufzunehmen oder möchten Sie den Hause lassen?
Warum können Sie das abhängig?
Welche Versuchungen machen Sie?
Ich sollte erst mal AKG schreiben und andere Untersuchungen durchführen, diese genaue Susagen.
Welche Versuchungen?
Ich habe AKG schon gesagt, und Abdomanzonografie und Röntgenaufnahme in zwei Ebenen.
Röntgen würden Sie machen? Warum Röntgen?
Zur weiteren Abklärung.
Was wollen Sie abklären?
Ich würde gerne sagen, ob eine Vergräserung von dem Herz vorliegt.
Für jede Situation, ich wollte bereit sein.
Machen Sie Röntgen vom Bauch oder Röntgen von Torax?
Torax und Abdomanz.
Beide Röntgen machen?
Ich würde gerne Elius.
Ich würde gerne Elius machen.
Was ist denn besser als Röntgen?
Was können Sie direkt in die Ambulanz machen?
Die Ambulanz-Zonografie ist schneller als Röntgen.
Sie machen gleich die Sonne.
Sie können schauen, ob Elius hat.
Sie können das Herz gucken.
Einmal hoch drücken.
Dann können Sie das Herz vergrößern.
Sie können auch andere Organe sehen.
Richtig.
Welches Organ würden Sie besonders angucken?
Ich würde gerne in diesem Zusammenhang gallen und Gas zu trinken.
Danke, das haben Sie gesagt.
Ja, ich würde gerne als Zusammenhang Gastrointestinal-Trakt so weit ich machen kann, ich würde gerne sehen.
Okay.
Was erwartet Sie im Labor?
Im Militant?
Im Militant, ja, ich würde Liebhaar, Amilas und die andere, Gamma, Golute, GGT und Komforto, das erlärt Sie nicht?
Sie haben eine Verdachtdiagnose, Sie haben eine Verdachtdiagnose, Akutupanctetitis.
Richtig?
Ja.
Was erwartet Sie, was in Blut, was erhöht es?
Ich würde als Liebhaar, Amilaswerte und Blu-Rubinwerte gucken.
Was erhöhte?
Erhöhte Liebhaar, Amilas, ich würde erwarten.
Erhöhte? Okay, was noch?
Und GGT, Blut-Senkuk, Geschwindigkeit, Leukoste.
CRP, CRP.
Ja, richtig, CRP und Leukostos, Blut-Senkuk, Geschwindigkeit.
Wenn Sie den Verdachtupanctetitis haben, auch immer die Elektrolyte mit abnehmen, Teilzonen zum Beispiel.
Ja, richtig.
Das ist auch noch wichtig, ob es nekotisches oder so was.
Okay.
Und dann nehmen Sie den Patienten auf oder lassen Sie den nach Hause?
Also ich würde in diesem Sammel nach, wenn diese Verdachtdiagnose sich erharten, sollte ich diese Patienten aufnehmen.
Und was machen Sie für Therapie?
Die Arzt ist, dass wir die Flüssigkeit und Elektrolyte so machen.
Okay.
Und dann für Antischmasmeter, ich würde gerne geben.
Und ja, und Schmasmeter geben.
Wenn die Lipase sehr hoch ist, sagen wir mal 10.000 oder 20.000?
Ich konnte nicht hören.
Wenn die Lipase sehr hoch ist, bei 10.000 oder 20.000, nehmen Sie den Patienten auf Normalstationen auf oder auf die Überwachungsstation?
Ja, Intensivstation, meinen Sie, richtig?
Überwachungsstation gibt es auch manchmal. Also Monitor, an Monitor, ne?
Ah ja.
Es kommt immer drauf an, wie stark die Entzündung ist.
Ja.
Verstanden?
Ja, ja, das habe ich verstanden.
Wenn er eine milde Entzündung hat, also eine leichte Entzündung hat, können Sie den auf Normalstation halten.
Aber wenn er sehr erhöhte Werte hat, dann sollte man schon den Patienten auch überwachen.
Herz, Röckens, Atemfrequenz, Blutdruck, ne?
Ja.
Richtig?
Richtig.
Würden Sie auch ein CD machen, eventuell? Computer-Thomografie?
Ja, weil ich Paket, das gesagt habe, Paketes, Pankreas befindet sich im Hinterbau, hinter Bereich des Abdomen, deswegen CD natürlich kommt im Betracht.
Aber ist es noch?
Warum?
Ja, zum besseren, zum Pankreas, können wir es sehen, sondern auch für die Anleitung.
Für andere differenzial, die Ökneose, als Urschillissen, CD, Bye-Bet, GG, binufals,
Nur CD oder CD mit Kontrastmitteln?
CD mit Kontrastmitteln.
Ja.
Okay.
Ich glaube, warum eine Paket ist?
Warum?
Ich habe einen Paket, der geht da.
Warum hat er die Pankretik?
Ja, weil er Oberbauschmess und Rückkehrnausstrahlung gesagt hat, aber es könnte, ich bin eigentlich...
Was ist die genäse der wahrscheinlich, also die genäse der Pankretik, der Grund?
Ja, er trinkt Alkohol und ist nicht so übergewichtig, aber trinkt Alkohol und er vielleicht verreist.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob sie fettige Nahrung hat oder nicht.
Er hat ja zwei Faktoren, er hat gesagt einmal Alkohol und einmal Blutfettwerte, die erhöht sind.
Ja, richtig.
Ich habe ja zum Beispiel auch nicht nur Kollisterinwett, auch Triglyceride.
Vielleicht meint er die Triglyceride.
Und wenn die Triglyceride auch immer erhöht sind, dann kann das auch eine Paketik verursachen.
Es muss nicht immer Alkohol sein.
Ja, aber es liegt im Grund natürlich, sie haben...
Ich habe nicht gesagt, als zugrund liegt ja die Perlipidämie und Alkohol am besten.
Genau, also über Triglyceridämie vielleicht, das ist auch ein Grund, eine Pankretik, das ist eine akuten Pankretik.
Kann sein, muss nicht sein.
Eine Kollegin hat die Autonetheorie, die Autonetheorie, keine, die Aufwärter und Falskene, die die Situation,
weil die Autonetheorie ist eine Symptome sehr anders.
Also..
Ich bedanke mich für diese solche Informationen in mein holy ars.
Und ja, ich würde gerne mit meinem Patienten und mit der Untersuchung anfangen.
Ja, schnell, der wartet schon.
Ja.
Gibt es noch andere Fragen, Ergänzungen?
Hab ich etwas falsch gesagt?
Hat der Herr Mehmet etwas falsch gesagt?
Ursache, Meistern, Alkoholkonsum und Gallenstein.
Richtig.
Oder auch Zegelzeridemi manchmal?
Ja, Residivpropylaxe, Was haben sie empfohlen, empfänden?
Ja, man sollte auf jeden Fall die Asso, Herr Mehmet, würde ich schon.
Ja, natürlich, Diet, Organisierung sollte erst mal gedacht werden.
Diet, der ist schon sehr dünn, erst organisiert.
Ja, kein Diet.
Er wird nur vorsichtig.
Ich meine, Alkoholabkunden, Abständen, fettarme Ernährung.
Wichtig ist Alkoholabstinenz.
Und, Hodja, Therapie beisigen.
Exzessive Alkoholkonsum mit Freunden in Hollands Vermeidung.
Hodja, in den Industrielldorf, der oft gefragte Therapie verhat,
welche Vitamine möchtest du empfehlen, Vitamine?
Also, ja, natürlich.
AD, EK, Vitamine, denken, weil die Zimtusambe und AD, EK, Vitamine, AD.
Und extra eine Therapie.
Keine Therapie, oder?
AD, EK, und, und, und, und, dann...
Ja, Dona, Insulentherapie, oder?